Let’s start off with a difficult question:
How do you define “reality?”
What is truly, “real?”
Is it simply a case of what we can see?
If something is known, as fact, and can be
proven to exist, does this make it real?
Is reality just the world around us, or is
there something more?
The goal of these questions isn’t to make
you question every part of the world around
you, or to question whether or not we are
all living in a computer simulation.
No, you’re asked this to help you understand
reality, because first of all, we aren’t
living in a simulation… we’re living in
a sitcom.
There is a wide ranging debate on what the
most powerful and dangerous SCPs ever encountered
are, but there is no denying the ever-present
danger of SCP-3812.
This Keter-class entity is regarded as highly
aggressive by the O5 Council, especially as
it has only ever been partially contained,
never fully.
The true scope of its abilities is currently
unknown, and any available information on
SCP-3812 is kept classified and secure by
the Foundation.
Needless to say, this entity poses a direct
threat not only to the SCP Foundation, but
to the very fabric of reality itself.
Contained within the file for SCP-3812 is
an excerpt from an article by one Doctor Robert
Scranton titled "Supersession and the Echelon
of Reality.”
In this article, Doctor Scranton posits a
theory about the nature of reality, and understanding
him is the first step towards understanding
SCP-3812.
His ”Recursive Stack” theory states that
there are different layers to reality, but
also that no single universe is “real.”
An easy way to think of it is to imagine a
sitcom, any sitcom you can envision will do.
Between us, and the fictional world of a sitcom,
there are multiple observable stacked universes.
Firstly, our universe, the ”real world”
as we experience it, forms the baseline, so
imagine this sitting at the top of the stack.
Next down in the stack comes the sitcom, a
fictional universe filled with characters,
which fits below our universe.
Then, think of what is fiction within the
fiction of the sitcom, perhaps another television
show, one that only exists in the world of
the sitcom, but not in our own.
This is the Recursive Stack, infinitely layered
universes, and it is crucial you can envision
and remember this model.
Doctor Scranton’s theory suggests that any
universe, even our own, could potentially
exist as a fictional narrative within another,
wider universe.
This wider universe, in which ours is a fiction,
could also itself be a narrative within an
even wider universe stacked above it, and
so on.
It’s interesting to picture reality this
way, isn’t it?
In fact, I’m willing to bet that you’re
wondering, maybe there’s a universe above
ours, or even one above that.
Would the universe right at the top of the
stack be the truly “real” world?
And what if you could travel between each
stacked reality?
If you are asking any of those questions,
then congratulations, you sound exactly like
SCP-3812.
SCP-3812 was previously known as Sam Howell.
While little is known about his life, Sam
was, as far as anyone knew, regarded as a
fairly ordinary human being.
Until his death in 1996, shortly after which
Sam rose from his grave and disappeared.
It is unknown whether SCP-3812 simply imitated
the form of Sam Howell, or if they are one
and the same, as this entity has been known
to have the ability to change forms at will,
making it hard for the Foundation to track
it.
It does usually maintain a humanoid appearance,
however this has deteriorated somewhat over
numerous decades.
By now, you may have already gathered that
the extent of SCP-3812’s abilities don’t
end at shape shifting.
This SCP is a powerful, aggressive, reality
altering entity.
Cast your mind back to the Recursive Stack.
SCP-3812 is able to travel upwards through
these stacked universes, creating untold chaos
using its plethora of world-bending abilities.
As far as the SCP Foundation can tell, 3812’s
sole intention is to become an omnipotent
force existing above any and all possible
universes.
In other words, the top of the stack.
Aside from the ability to change shape, SCP-3812’s
control and alteration of a reality around
it is achieved by its long list of latent
abilities.
This entity is capable of feats far beyond
that of normal humans such as teleportation,
telekinesis, telepathy.
However, SCP-3812 is also able to directly
manipulate any and all aspects of reality.
It can influence and alter observable forces
around us, for example the manipulation of
matter, energy, weather, and even gravity
and other Laws of Physics as we know them.
But the creature can also warp reality on
further levels.
It’s able to erase people, objects or even
concepts to the point where human beings lose
virtually all memory of them.
With the danger that an entity this powerful
poses to our reality, it’s not surprising
that the SCP Foundation would attempt to nullify
its abilities.
One attempt by the Foundation involved another,
unknown SCP which created an anti-metaphysical
field.
This was done in the hopes that this would
strip SCP-3812 of its reality warping abilities,
however the entity was unfazed, the containment
attempt failed, and the remains of the unknown
SCP instead resulted in the creation of SCP-239.
As for the SCP-3812 entity’s own origin,
that is still largely unknown.
But there does exist a message on a secure
server in the SCP Foundation’s O5 Command,
seemingly from another entity belonging to
a reality stacked higher above our own, that
appears to have created a reality much further
down, one that SCP-3812 inhabited.
And now it seems that SCP-3812 is climbing
up the stack.
There is a trade-off of sorts to the abundance
of powers SCP-3812 possesses.
The entity is in an almost constant state
of ascension through different stacked universes,
climbing higher and higher, believing every
reality beneath it to be a fiction.
The creature has developed multiple, severe
mental conditions that seem to be a direct
result of overexposure to different layers
of reality.
This includes an advanced form of Eigenmann-Veitor
schizophrenia complex, which often manifests
in extreme symptoms within the creature.
SCP-3812 has been known to suffer from paranoia,
dysphoria, depression, an inability to control
its emotions, as well as hearing voices, seeing
things that do not exist and possessing multiple
personalities.
While the creature is usually aimless, SCP-3812
has been known to have random outbursts that
can cause anomalies within local space and
time.
But, thanks to it experiencing so many different
layers of reality, traveling upwards through
what it perceives to be fictional universes,
SCP-3812 displays difficulty in separating
what is real, and what is imagined.
In fact, reality and fiction have become one
and the same to SCP-3812, because as far as
it is concerned, they literally are the same.
Each new reality it inhabits is just fiction
for the reality stacked above it.
So then how are we supposed to contain or
neutralize such a powerful reality altering
creature that cannot distinguish between what
is real and what is fictional?
The Foundation knows that its own procedures
to keep SCP-3812 contained would be ineffective.
This entity, by its nature, cannot be contained.
Any attempt to keep it locked away would easily
be undone by any one of its numerous powers
to warp reality.
Locking it in a cement box at the bottom of
the ocean would be pointless.
It could teleport out, or turn its cell into
nothing but dust.
Putting it in a vat of acid to endlessly burn
it would just result in it turning that acid
to harmless water, or air.
SCP-3812 can manipulate events throughout
time, and so it could easily prevent itself
from ever being contained.
It is even possible that any individuals,
even Foundation staff, who may have previously
tried to luck the creature up, now no longer
exist thanks to SCP-3812’s abilities, and
there would be no way to determine this since
we wouldn’t be able to remember that the
person had ever been in our reality.
The Foundation’s best hope is to keep SCP-3812
where it is, and hope it remains docile.
If they are able to keep it away from large
population centers, then the risk of 3812
having any sort of psychic influence over
civilians, or warping reality and causing
the deaths of millions or even billions, is
at least reduced.
But of course it’s never fully gone.
On at least one occasion SCP-3812 has caused
a truly catastrophic event.
For some reason, SCP-3812 decided to turn
itself into a star, spinning endlessly.
As it did so, numerous anomalous occurrences
took place across the world.
Most notably, SCP-3812 caused the Foundation’s
nuclear warheads to detonate, spreading harmful,
radioactive material into the atmosphere.
Additionally, the population of New Zealand
began to sporadically disappear and reappear,
looping back and forth between existence and
non-existence for a period of around five
hours.
It was during this world ending scenario that
SCP-3812, still at the center of its star
form, was recorded ranting, its split personalities
arguing.
One of the creature’s personalities claimed
it was “unmaking the world” as an act
of revenge against someone.
It stated that it believed, “Existence is
a joke.
The narrative abandoned us to be miserable
and we are breaking the narrative.”
Its other half mentioned another entity, known
only as “Ben”, and seemed to imply that
this entity was responsible for SCP-3812’s
creation, in a reality stacked above this
one.
According to the more rational of 3812’s
two halves, this ”Ben” entity “deemed
us unfit to rest peacefully.
To slip into the darkness, quietly.
He made a game of us.”
It then went on to convince its other half
that destroying this reality just to slight
Ben would be pointless.
There would always be another, stacked on
top, infinitely.
“So why does this narrative mean anything
to you?”
it asked.
“It is one of an eternity of others.
It is not special.
It is not particular.”
The two sides of SCP-3812 argued with each
other, one wanting to destroy all of reality
to spite Ben, driven mad by witnessing trillions
upon trillions of universes stacked atop each
other.
The other half of 3812 saw peace for itself,
ascending above these infinitely stacked universes,
finally reaching the top and becoming free.
“Not a god.
A star, rising in the east.
Rising away from this all until we are little
more than a memory of a song.”
“It will be lonely,” the other half of
the creature replied.
“We’ll have each other,” SCP-3812’s
other personality said.
“I’m afraid,” said the one intent on
destruction.
“I am too,” the other reassured it, “But
that is no reason to destroy this narrative.”
Eventually, SCP-3812’s personalities reached
agreement.
They both left the narrative they were currently
in, presumably traveling upwards to one stacked
above our own, while simultaneously remaining
in this universe.
Still a danger.
“Let go of this world.
Let him rewrite it back to what it was.
We aren’t part of this anymore.”
Shortly after this event, reality shifted
once more and the entire world reverted back
to how it had been before.
Records of the end of the world scenario that
had occurred were retained by high-level administrators
and the O5 Council, perhaps as a reminder
of the destructive capabilities of the creature,
a warning of its potential to change this
reality and any stacked below or above it.
Fortunately, since this incident, SCP-3812
has remained in its docile, aimless state,
no longer actively hostile to anyone that
approaches it.
It has kept its amorphous, star-like shape,
and is still very much able to create disruptions
and anomalies in reality.
Despite keeping SCP-3812 constantly monitored
at its current location in the South Pacific
Ocean, the SCP Foundation knows that, at any
time, this entity could trigger yet another
global catastrophe, causing massive damage
to planet Earth, its population, and beyond
that, tearing our reality itself asunder.
So we all just better hope our narrative remains
worthwhile to SCP-3812’s better half...
Now check out “SCP-1861 - The Crew of the
HMS Wintersheimer” and “SCP-1765 - The
Sisters” for more reality-warping madness
from the SCP Foundation!